having someone understanding leads I'm a
property investor I've bought a lot of
houses over the last decade more than a
decade in fact and I do regular training
and YouTube videos teaching other people
to invest in property and you know what
I wanted to say on this video right now
2020 this is a really bad time to buy a
house right now right now is a terrible
time to invest in property if you do not
know what you're doing if you do not
follow the three golden rules for 2020
property investing now listen the reason
it's a bad time is because house prices
are going down right now
so if you buy a house right now and it
goes down you're gonna go oh my gosh
she's come down and then you probably
sell it and you lose money on your
second property investing I lost money
people do lose money in recessions and
right now we are in a recession so it's
a bad time but if you're smart and you
know what you're doing and you follow
the three golden rules then it's a
really friggin good time but you gotta
follow the three golden rules and on
this video guess what you'll be pleased
to know I'm gonna share with you the
three golden rules that I'm personally
doing and I'm teaching my students to do
to make this an opportunity instead of a
danger and that's this number one do not
pay full market value get properties
only in 2020 right now that are below
market value and I mean heavily below
market value because as I said you buy a
house for 200 grams and then it drops to
150 which you probably will do over the
next year or two drops to 150 sure
enough it's going to bounce back up but
you've just lost money because if you
buy it for 150 straightaway right now
based on what's gonna happen then
suddenly you've just got a good deal and
your return on investments better
because rents aren't going down so as
properties go down that just brings more
opportunity so that's the first thing
below market value right now some
sellers are being pretty stubborn
because they're not aware that
properties are gonna fall and they're
saying but my house is worth 200 grand
and you're saying yes it is but like if
they're gonna fall so you're using that
as a reason to get a cheaper deal don't
fall in love with properties don't get
hit
you know about properties just get
formulas not feelings this has to be
below market value if you're buying
properties below market value in your
bottom 20% below market value if they do
dip by 10 or 15% this year which is what
they're predicted to do even if they dip
a little bit further you're still in the
green so that's the first thing but
there's two more golden rules second
goal of all is this make sure it's
giving you positive cash flow every
single month so simple but listen some
of my students are buying houses and and
they don't care if it goes down in value
I bought houses in 2009-2010 and they
crashed and their properties went down
in value but unless you sell them it
doesn't matter I bought I bought houses
rented them out as HMOs was getting a
nice cash flow financially free then the
crash happened and as the problems
continue to go down everyone said to me
Orbitz you're worried I'm like no why
would I be worried my houses have gone
down in value which means technically my
net worth is decreased but my cash flow
is still the same and I'm still
financially free because rents aren't
going down and in recessions normally
what happens if anything quits go up so
second goal of all make sure that you've
got cash flow coming in from the
property go to rule number three if you
can do that if you can do all three your
friggin eye laughing okay go to wall
number three is when you buy a property
find ways to push the value up in the
put on the property so what I mean by
this is if it rather than just buying a
house and just buying it and renting out
by it and then force the value up so for
instance the property might not have a
working kitchen and bathroom might not
be habitable so you can buy really
really cheap especially as it's not
habitable needs work and we're in the
middle of a recession you get it really
cheap and then you get a new kitchen get
a new bathroom and force the value up on
the property and then what's happening
is you buy it at the low market value
you make sure you get good cash flow on
it once it's done up and then you're
forcing the value up I just had one of
my students phoned me up yesterday who
said that they just secured a HMO
property they're going to convert it
into a hey check my property and it's
going to be a 6 bed commercial HMO
property and they're gonna be able to
push the value up and it's going to be
on a commercial value basis a commercial
value basis that means that the values
not based on the
bricks and mortar the values based on
the rent and so it's like very very safe
so he's gonna push the value up it's
gonna then pull all of his money back
out on a buy to let vine out so there's
just literally when you when you know
how to push the value up on properties
it's called the buy refurbish refinance
strategy and you're adding value you
you're gonna win in this time
combined with positive cash flow
combined with buying below market value
you seek this opportunity right now and
you make the most of an opportunity what
does Grant Cardone say it says never
miss a good crisis you know never waste
as good recession is what Grant Cardone
says so I'm excited I'm doing deals
right now also some of the deals but I'm
doing now a properties that I viewed 12
months ago tried to negotiate an option
agreement or at some sort of a deal they
said no now they're coming back to me so
and if you it's sort of some of the
people and YouTube comments a lot saying
it's a really bad time to invest to save
your pennies I love it when people say
that because when the taxi drivers are
talking about how good Bitcoin is that's
when you want to get out when people are
scared that's when you should be greedy
James Caan from Dragon's Den what does
he say just observe the masses and do
the opposite so my advice for you right
now is this if you don't know anything
about property you're inexperienced when
you thinking of just putting your money
into a dream home don't do it right now
wait but if you're trained smart
entrepreneur then seize the opportunity
become financially free in 2020 this is
your year if you found this video
helpful please use to match the like
button subscribe drop a nice comment in
below and I look forward to seeing you
next time peace out